welcome back to cbs mornings at 7 30
where we're continuing our series
mornings in the metaverse with a look at
some of the potential risks that people
could face
in that emerging virtual world the
metaverse can look and feel more real
than the online social interactions and
gaming experiences that we're used to
but that can leave consumers potentially
vulnerable and there's a lot of money at
stake researchers predict that the
global metaverse market could be worth
about 680 billion dollars in just a few
years by 2030. consumer investigative
correspondent anna warner spoke with
cyber security experts who say that
where the money goes the criminals soon
follow
if you want to know what can be great
about the metaverse talk to 12 year old
cooper stone the metaverse is a virtual
reality world where you can go to
concerts
you can see famous and really cool
people around the world
cooper plays video games like fortnite
and uses his virtual reality headset to
play sports and in the future those
experiences will likely seem much more
real as jason rubin of metta formerly
called facebook told cbs news in
february in an interview conducted in
their virtual reality program but slowly
but surely i think the things you can do
in the metaverse and the amount of time
you spend in virtual reality in the meta
worse will slowly increase to the point
where we really uh become an immersive
world so it's no surprise that companies
are seeking ways to create experiences
and make money in the metaverse but
where there's money to be made the
criminals won't be far behind we totally
expect them to move into this kevin
goschalk is with cyber security firm
arcos labs the moment there's a
valid metaverse spun up that has a real
money mechanism where they can make
money they'll be in their day one he
showed us how in chat rooms
conversations are already going on about
how to exploit the metaverse for fraud
to sell identities to sell social
security numbers essentially what you're
saying is that when it comes to scams
everything old is new again it's just in
the metaverse now right the way they do
it may be slightly different but what
they're trying to achieve money
and the goal of doing it duping somebody
and giving them money they're going to
be aligned
cooper stone and his parents say they
already got scammed when hackers broke
into his fortnite account last year and
charged up his parents credit cards they
were like cooper did you spend
25 or 50 on this game without my
permission i'm like no we investigated a
little bit more and
found out that he had not done it
everyone is looking to make money off
the metaverse and the hackers go where
the money is
and caroline wong with cyber security
firm cobalt io says criminal's attacks
can take on more disturbing forms for
example if a hacker gains access to your
vr headset if a hacker can access that
camera
they can see into your office they can
see into your bedroom
they can see inside of your home that's
called the camera attack another one
is called the overlay attack
when they can
control what you're seeing
and what you're hearing so in other
words they're going to change what you
see and what you hear yes right into
what they want you to see in here yes
and because you're so immersed people
may actually have a trauma response
not only that some content in the
metaverse might be disturbing to some
users especially children as wong and i
saw when we donned headsets to visit
some vr worlds
in a program called vr chat we found
users some who clearly sounded like
children making crude drawings we can't
show here
oh okay yeah graffiti i think i know
what these folks are trying to draw
and in a user-created room in meta's
horizon worlds we were able to pick up
guns lying randomly around a house as
other users fired them off
that's not that's not comforting another
user who sounded like a young child
played with one of those guns the gun
down
put the gun down i'm the officer
no don't push it
so i guess the question is whether you
want your child in here
i would say definitively no
metta told us quest headsets are
designed for children ages 13 and up
with some experiences only for people 18
and up the company says it has set up
safe zones inside the software so users
can exit situations they might find
uncomfortable and later this month will
offer a way for parents to lock specific
apps that aren't age appropriate for
teens vr chat told us underage users are
not permitted and are banned if detected
and that user safety is a top priority i
think you know i hear the company saying
well it's just like the real world you
can't protect against everything you
can't protect against everything but
there are things that you can do they
build the world
they create the experiences everything
is being monitored
already
all of that's being monitored
it can be monitored it is the
appropriate thing to do it is absolutely
possible and
it costs money and resources to do so so
they have to be willing to step up and
do it that's right
the goal both she and the companies say
is to create safe enjoyable experiences
for all in a new virtual world i'm anna
werner for cbs mornings in san francisco
anna thank you we should let our viewers
know that the company that owns fortnite
that's epic games told us it has uh
bought controls for parents to manage
fortnite purchases and quote checks all
accounts for signs of compromise
continuously to help stop fraud meta
fritz bart also told us in may they'll
offer additional parental supervision
tools to monitor their teen's activities
i know i sound like a boomer even though
i'm not but i'm like i'll just hang out
in the real world for now yeah i mean i
am a boomer and i'm gonna say i just
want to hang out in the real world as a
parent overlay attack tony where it says
they can control what you're seeing and
what you're hearing i thought miss wong
was very good yeah and and what the
heads up that she was giving everybody
clearly work to be done yeah i'm already
sweating bullets as a parent here but
when they put it on parents to police it
it's difficult because i can barely you
know you can barely figure out your own
phone uh and keep the fraud out of that
from the real world let alone uh keeping
uh control of what your kids are doing
yeah and the fact that kids are in the
metaverse like spring obscene graffiti
in the virtual world i mean they do that
in the real world so why would we expect
that that behavior would not transfer
actually if it's a choice between riding
on a real building and riding on a fake
building go for it go for the fake
building right yeah at least you won't
get in trouble
to be continued for sure